a little over 10 years ago I produced a
video that had to do with depression
with my own experience with it and
things that I found helpful things that
I thought were less than helpful and I
put it out there because I've always
been quite public about this and I
thought it could be useful and I also
had quite a few subscribers and readers
and listeners who were saying you know
can you say something about this perhaps
because they they knew that I've
struggled with it and also perhaps
because they were struggling with it
themselves and you know it's 10 years
down the line I've been thinking about
doing an update for that you know quite
a long time and I had a recent exchange
on Twitter that kind of catalyzed that
I'm now finished with giving to
conference presentations so I got a
little bit of extra time on my hands so
anyway it was with a colleague of mine
who was talking about you know dealing
with what we would call more severe
depression I strong struggle with mild
to moderate depression and this person
was worse off but had come through it
and you know I sort of you know
exchanged some some tweets back and
forth saying yeah I struggle with this
kind of thing too I understand what it's
like and you know we got to be kind of
careful because depression names a lot
of different things that are all put
together under one umbrella so we don't
always know exactly what it's like for
another person but you know we can
relate as they say and so I thought I
would do an update and that's what this
video is and so I do want to say
something right off the bat just to head
off any problems if you're going to
leave comments on this and I'm very
happy if you do
don't make it about giving people advice
because you don't know any of the other
people who are struggling with it who
might be watching it you don't know me
really that well and people who think
they have the magic bullet or the Cure
or the way to look at depression they're
wrong you know they're it's not as
simple as well you just got to do this
and then everything's going to fall into
place or depression stems just from this
again it's it's complex so if you've got
that temptation to shoot off a comment
giving people advice resist that
Temptation exercise some self-control
okay that put out of the way what about
the video itself it's been 10 years and
almost a month so it's had 28 000 plus
views which is great
um hundreds of comments many people
found it quite helpful I think a lot of
people could they were happy that some
somebody was talking publicly about this
because even in the 2020s
there's still a stigma attached to
whatever we want to call it you know
mental illness depression all of these
sorts of things Behavioral Health we've
got all sorts of synonyms for it and
there's a lot of people who feel very
alone and that is indeed part of the
dynamic of depression in a lot of cases
this feeling like ah I'm the only one
who's struggling with it so I'm here to
say uh no you're not and by looking at
the number of comments on the previous
video which I'll I'll link to you can
see that there's just tons and tons of
people out there who are undergoing you
know not exactly the same but similar
struggles so I've been meaning to update
this for quite a while I think it's it's
helpful for those of us who have
struggled with continue to struggle with
things like depression to put it out
there and to allow other people to you
you know relate to it to not feel quite
so on their own and you know it's I do
want to avoid two Extremes in this one
of the extremes is presenting yourself
just as a sufferer oh it's my cross to
bear it's so terrible I mean it does
suck right objectively speaking and and
subjectively but we're not just passive
victims of this thing that we call
depression and I also want to avoid this
other extreme of you know I pulled
myself up by my bootstraps or got
through it using this thing and you
could be just like me I think that's a a
mistaken point of view to take as well
so I'm not going to be giving you advice
I'm just going to be sharing with you
updates and my own experiences and you
know things that other people have said
that I have sound useful but I'm not
going to say here's the path to you know
use philosophy to Grapple with your
depression or anything like that I mean
there's enough people out there doing
that sort of thing I don't need to
replicate it so
let me start by saying one thing right
off the bat that I had kind of lower
down in my my notes but I think it's
really important to highlight
at the beginning so if you suffer from
depression or if you're you know blue
and you don't know why and yet you're
never actually gone and got a diagnosis
or anything like that I sympathize with
you and that's about as far as we can go
I don't have to say that I've walked a
mile in your shoes or that I know
exactly what it feels like for you
depression affects people in many
different ways but I think it is useful
to know that people understand what it's
like you know depression is complex it's
very subjective and I think getting your
head around your own depression and that
of others maybe you don't you're not
depressed but you've got somebody in
your family or among your friends or
colleagues who's depressed wrapping your
head around it that's that's a useful
thing to do a good thing to do I think
and there isn't any one single or simple
way to do that it's not it's a problem
that's sort of like a big ball of
knotted yarn uh where you got to pull
one thread and then pull another one I
mean you can do the Alexander gordian
knot thing and just cut it in half but
that's not great if you actually want to
have the yarn and unravel it so enough
of that metaform I'll give you my
updates first and then I want to hit on
some of the things that I talked about
in the previous video 10 years ago and
maybe a few new things as well so in the
previous video I mentioned that I was
taking Wellbutrin what we call a
maintenance dose I'm happy to say that I
have been able to go off of it which is
good because you know we don't know what
the very long term effects you know
taking these things for decades and
decades really is going to be and a lot
of Medicaid education can mess with
other things as well so it's good for me
that I got off of it again I'm not
giving anybody advice that like if
you've got meds get off them right away
or something like that I mean for a lot
of people they're very helpful my uh
Uncle amay who died a couple years ago
he was severely bipolar he benefited
greatly by having access to medications
that Hattie uh been you know prescribed
back when he was a teenager and 20
something and 30 something man his life
would have had an entirely different
trajectory but it wasn't until his 40s
that he started getting the care that he
needed I was able to go off of it and
that's that's good for me
um
I'm in better shape physically for the
most part you know I get regular walks
in and walks are important not just to
get exercise but also like you know
change the scenery like if you live in a
place and it's just this all the time
that can kind of wear on you being
exposed to Nature is also something that
can be quite helpful for many people and
I've been you know I think about for
four years now off and on doing the
weight circuit which I find enjoyable
and which has helped me both in terms of
gaining muscle losing some of the fat
that I had you know gaining endurance
and and things along those lines so that
that's good and I would say that my life
is more well integrated at this point in
time but you know the the last decade
there have been a lot of losses a lot of
setbacks a lot of challenges that I've
had to deal with and you know sometimes
those would get me down considerably and
we'll talk about you know grief and
depression in just a bit but just to
mention you know when I moved in with my
then fiance now wife Andy when I moved
up to New York in 2011
she had two dogs and two cats that
became my dogs and cats as well they're
all gone since the last since the last
video they've all passed away it was
first Teensy and she died you know in
cat middle age and then it was Magnus
and Amica and sassy and you might say oh
they're just animals well I was very
close to them especially to sassy so you
know there's that I mentioned that my
uncle died you know you know there have
been other losses along the way as well
and so you know some of that going on
and uh you know
um changes in work
I've done a lot of different jobs since
then some of them quite good some of
them lasting a long time like you know
working at Milwaukee Institute of Art
and Design other places I left and you
know needed to get the hell out of that
particular relationship or it just
simply didn't work out and we broke it
off on on both sides so you know there's
been some personal things professional
and and bodily too you know I'm 10 years
older if you look at the old video and
this one you notice that you know my
beard is white I'm 10 years older
in the process I've uh wound up with
with diabetes which has you know led to
chain you know adding more exercise
changing diet cutting out alcohol things
like that
um and some of that is genetic and some
of that is is a product of the way I
lived for years and years and years but
it's it's not something fun right so
there's a lot of different things and
and everybody can talk about losses
setbacks challenges there's there's also
been a lot of great stuff along the way
I've engaged in a lot of projects I mean
one of the things I'll say right off the
bat in terms of personal life you know
my wife and I both people who got
knocked around a lot by life before we
found our way back to each other we knew
each other from high school and both of
us are rather choleric people uh you
know and uh used to living our own way
and you put people like that together
and it takes a lot of work to you know
learn how to live with each other even
if you love each other right and we've
gotten better and better and better at
that over time I've also had the chance
to see my children growing up from my
previous marriage one now is in going
into senior year of college here in
Milwaukee
another is going into junior year of
high school you know so at one time well
way back then they were just kids and
now they're not really kids anymore and
it's wonderful to see the changes the
growth but it's not like Easy Street I
mean raising kids being involved in
their life a lot of stuff going on with
that including what happens to them and
how you take what's going on with that
I've engaged in a lot of different
projects I've produced a lot of not just
videos but writing and podcasts and you
know taught a lot of classes had I don't
know how many students passed through my
either virtual or face-to-face
classrooms lots of different clients
that I've worked with and so you know
it's been a busy decade you could say
so that's uh ones you know that that's
that's the updates right I would say
that on the whole I'm better off
considerably better off than I was 10
years ago and I was better off 10 years
ago than I was 10 years before that when
I was in a bad marriage uh that I got
into you know making some some misguided
decisions in depression in grief you
know all those sorts of matters so
um that's enough about the updates I
want to consider some of the things that
I talked about before so
if you don't know my back history about
this I have been dealing with what we
can recognize now as depression really
since
um adolescence and it's it's not all
that surprising my childhood was not the
easiest one my grandmother who I was
very close to died when I was seven uh
her son my dad died when I was 11 and my
mom you know had to go back to work we
had my alcoholic grandfather living with
us you know our younger sister and we're
dealing with a lot of of stuff and
nobody really had the the vocabulary or
the coping techniques or things like
that to adequately deal with it and it
wound up you know in my case leading to
a lot of aggression winding up becoming
a ward of the Court spending some time
in a psychiatric institution where I
actually got a bit of care that I needed
but a lot of it was more like seeing
people who are way worse off and being
like holy crap you know my problems
aren't actually as bad as this person or
this person or this person thank God I
don't need to be on medication and then
you know some talk therapy and things
like that and you know I think that in
you know in the 70s and the 80s and even
into the 90s
um a lot of these things weren't as well
understood or you know not talked about
as adequately as they have been since
then
um so you know
there's there's been a lot of growth in
this respect but it's not like you know
one constant
um
Ascent right there's there's
what we call uh troughs and you know
plateaus and and things like that
and one of the things that I have really
thought a lot about and learned over the
years both
um
for myself and for people that I'm close
to and also in sometimes helping
colleagues or clients or you know other
other people sometimes even students
coming in and talking during office
hours about these kinds of matters is
you know depression as I mentioned this
metaphor of like a very complex knot
that has a lot of different threads in
it that you got to kind of pull apart
and that that's that's true depression
is something that is complex it's also
what we can call a
self-reinforcing Dynamics so you know
when you're depressed
um depression helps to keep you in
depression
a lot of things are like that right it's
not unique that way and I don't even
want to say that it's like the most that
way but it certainly is a major part of
it you think about what depression tends
to impose on people you know not just
like feeling blue or sad or a lack of
Interest or
um
ability to to commit and see things
through but also sort of a distraction
you know all of these feed into each
other you you know here's a part of the
dynamic again not unique to depressive
people but procrastination right you
procrastination and perfectionism going
hand in hand where you're like oh you
know I'm gonna do this thing and it's
going to be great and I'm going to put
all this work into and it's going to
make me feel good as a result although
that's not why I'm doing it it's
intrinsically worthwhile and all that
and then you start doing parts of it
that you like working on and you put off
the other parts and then because you've
put them off you feel bad about that
you're not on schedule anymore and now
you gotta like work extra hard to bring
it all back on schedule and I'll make a
I'll make a flow chart I'll make a uh
you know spreadsheet about this and you
start doing all sorts of other things as
well and some of the things get done and
late or half-assed or your heart isn't
fully in it and then you feel kind of
crappy about that right I mean this is
just one of many different dynamics that
that people do often fall into
and there's a book that I read I've read
quite a few books about this matter but
I would say for me the book that I
actually got the most out of
wasn't by a psychologist or psychiatrist
or therapist it was actually by a
reporter somebody who himself suffered
with and had mistaken conceptions about
depression and then did a lot of
research and wrote it down there's a
book called Lost connections and there's
a long subtitle to it that I'll I'll put
in the video description below by Johann
Hari and I I really liked what he had to
say because he also recognized
depression isn't something that has like
a single cause and it works the same way
every time it's about a whole bunch of
different matters that have kind of gone
off and he framed it in terms of the
title lost connections how are we
connected to other people
how do we connect to the work that we do
right how do we connect to the
environment the natural world how do we
connect to
um
that you know people as we're as we're
growing how do we connect to ourselves
do we feel alienated from who we are do
we dislike who we are and he looks at
these sort of like each in turn I don't
want to say that he's got like the Magic
Bullet because obviously there isn't one
for this but I think
um he's he's got a great uh discussion
of that and so you know we can have
disconnections or difficulties in
maintaining connections with all these
different dimensions you know our love
life our work life our uh relationship
to our own body to
um how we are as we age all of these
things can
wear upon us all these things could
become sources not just of Joy but of
anxiety or sadness or anger or all sorts
of other negative emotions that fit
within this Dynamic and so that's one
important Dimension I think another that
I think that makes depression difficult
is that it's what we can call a hobby
tooth uh you know and this this is a
Latin word that we often translate as
habit but it's more than just a habit
it's like a Nexus of habits and actions
and choices and emotional responses and
moods and ideas about things maybe some
of which we've come up with ourselves
and others we've gotten from the culture
around us or people that are important
in our lives and you can have good ones
and you can have bad ones those that you
know wear upon you so you know thought
processes uh our relationships that we
have the choices that we make all of
these get bound into and this is how we
relate to the world is how we exist in
time as a certain philosophies would
would tell us these
lasting you know bodies of habits and so
if we want the depression to be
different we got to kind of chip away at
this and it's not like you can just take
a pill or flip a switch in your brain
that's automatically going to make you
feel okay about stuff it takes it takes
thought it takes work it takes
failures and you know dealing with those
and transforming those not necessarily
into successes but good enough right
and
um you know there's also an interesting
conversation that came up in the
previous video and some people wanted to
argue about in comments and I I said in
the previous video
when it comes to psychology many people
fall into this fallacious false
dichotomy is it nature is it nurture
right and we've heard this so many times
I have students who come into my class
and every time we're going to talk about
some issue of moral responsibility
that's where their focus is and we
forget that there's more than just
nature and nurture I mean it's cover a
lot of ground
but we also have at least some limited
capacity
to choose what do you want to call that
the will or not you don't have to like
believe in some big capital F big
capital W free will we certainly do have
some measure of freedom and choice you
know in some people's cases it's smaller
I mean if you're feeling so crappy that
you have a hard time getting out of bed
and brushing your teeth and taking a
shower obviously you don't have the same
range of freedom and choice as somebody
who has no problem doing that every
single morning who gets up to cheery
whistling looking forward to the day but
you do have some
you have some measure and you know I
don't want to like say oh well therefore
everything you you do and feel is your
responsibility no but you want to
realize that you have some capacity to
to choose and to decide how things are
going to go for you and that allows you
to make a little bit of progress here
and a little bit of progress there and a
little bit here and a little bit there A
lot of times it involves going against
what your brain is telling you you know
or what your feelings are guiding you
towards or what your habits currently
are your routine right taking risks
little risks not always huge risks
um
taking the chance of thinking
differently you know and seeing if that
ever leads to feeling differently doing
activities that maybe you're not a
hundred percent or even 70 or 30 or 10
invested in these are choices that we
can make and you know when we understand
how our depression works and it's going
to be different for for different people
we can see what choices we need to pay
more attention to and which we can kind
of let slide
um
and so I think a lot of people get into
abstract silliness where they're too
worried about the metaphysics of this
you know I had one person for example
who was saying you say that it's nurture
and nature uh and then this third
element of choice well that choice just
boils down to nurture in nature and you
know when I encounter people like that
who often are prisoners of their own
thought processes I say to them well how
the hell do you know that on what
dogmatic basis are you asserting for all
humankind through all history that
things are only and exactly this way we
don't actually know that and so you know
some healthy skepticism can actually be
quite useful for pulling yourself out of
some of these these thought prisons
let's call them another thing that I
want to bring up is you know what what's
useful for people how how do you chip
away at this
and there were quite a few people who
were discussing therapy but people get
very abstract again and very
black and white about therapy oh guys
don't go to therapy well you know
it depends on who the therapist is and
what modality they're using and what
your interaction is like not every
therapist not every kind of therapy is
for every person and not all therapists
are actually good at what they do or
ethical individuals who aren't going to
be you know uh engaging with you in ways
that could be counterproductive for you
therapy can be on the whole quite useful
and I'm a big advocate of trying to find
therapists that you can work with but
it's not always available for everybody
especially here in the United States you
know where our health care System often
doesn't help us much with mental health
or you're stuck with this person here
for 12 sessions and that's all you get
Jack you know unless you want to pay
tons and tons of money so you know
therapy can be very helpful but there's
a lot of if this is the case if this is
the case a lot of provisos a lot of what
we could call all
qualifiers involved studying philosophy
can be useful as well I mean it helped
me in many respects there's many other
people out there but it's got to be the
right kind of philosophy and doing it in
the right ways and sometimes you need
some guidance with that or you know
you can't do you can't you know set the
bar way too high for yourself because
then you just make yourself feel like
crap again right so you know there's
there's lots of of things
um support groups or you know as we call
them support networks talking with your
family your friends
um you know if you're lucky enough your
your significant other that can often be
quite helpful
um on the other hand
you know sometimes they can actually be
counterproductive they can make you feel
like crap for being depressed they blame
everything on your depression right so
it's all kind of you need to like look
into the specifics of the situation
um and you know there's all sorts of
other things you can change what you're
eating
um you can change your sleep patterns
you can add more exercise you can do
different kinds of exercise you can make
sure that you get out in nature that you
find some small joys for yourself during
the day to
provide yourself you know those those
can be quite helpful as well another
thing that I talked about in the video
that I think anybody who's struggling
with any sort of uh
you know mental health issue or disorder
can relate to you know if you're
depressed it's not just about feeling
sad or being gloomy or Melancholy
there's often other affects that are
connected to it my own particular form
sometimes would take the the shape of
anger and that's you know studying how
anger works and what we can do about it
has been incredibly helpful for me I'll
also mention that anxiety has been a
significant problem for me over the
years those are both lessened for me in
the last 10 years I'm happy to say
and that's part of why I'm you know less
depressed you could say and it may be
other things for other people I think
there's there's a lot of different
constellations of these things so you
know you kind of want to look into that
and if you're dealing with somebody else
who's depressed even if you're depressed
they might not they might not have
exactly the same thing going on for them
as you do within you so it's important
to be attentive to that I think
um you know I'll mention another thing
too you know
it's common not only in general but also
in specific cultures to be using relying
upon substances that affect our our
moods if you are depressed and sometimes
these can go hand in hand so like you
know I mean I'm I'm I'll say it right
now I'm addicted to caffeine I have two
pots of coffee just about every day now
I also have a gene that makes me less uh
responsive to what caffeine does so it
doesn't give me the Jitters or stuff
like that but I'm not going without
caffeine and specifically coffee but you
know I used to smoke tobacco and I quit
that not quite 10 years ago but quite a
while ago and I'm better off for that
and you know
I I've actually done a video about how
much I like smoking so I'll put a link
to that below and you can hear about all
that
um cutting back on drinking and then
cutting out drinking alcohol all
together has been on the whole a
positive I know that certainly in in the
past
um
I I drank a lot you know basically from
my teenage years you know through being
in the Army being in college being in
graduate school being a young Professor
for years and years and years and years
I even you know brewed my own beer for
quite a while and that was that was a
lot of fun but
um
you know was that helpful in dealing
with depression probably not on the
whole right
um now there's you know there's I'm not
knocking it all together there's a
social aspect conviviality but it can
also become kind of a crutch and you
know realizing for example that it's
it's easier to like get into arguments
when you're you know intoxicated or even
just a bit buzzed maybe that's something
that you cut back on right and you might
say oh but you're cutting out one of my
joys in life ah true but there's so many
other things that you can find as Joys
as well and so in in my long journey
I've found that to be quite uh useful
um
another thing that I I brought up was
um you know making bad decisions in the
course of your life and this goes back
to that like depression is a
self-reinforcing dynamic in certain
respects so you know when you're when
you're depressed chronically and
particularly when you're in a depressive
State you do see the world and
relationships and your prospects and
what's possible for you and we can go on
and on and on in different ways than
maybe other people do right and it's not
to say that you're not your point of
view isn't actually in touch with
reality I mean it's funny I think I may
have mentioned this that uh in this
seminar that I had uh that I was part of
with Aleister McIntyre we got into a
discussion about
does depression or being depressive or
looking on you know the the harsher side
of life being tender-minded as William
James calls it
does that give you a closer access to
how things are and McIntyre himself said
you know I suffer from depression and
our consensus was if you're mildly
depressed you're probably so in part
because you do see how you know
imperfect and crappy and and you know uh
contingent things are right as opposed
to the optimists who you know wander
through life
everything's so great you know like Mr
Magoo
um but that doesn't mean that you're
totally in touch with things and so you
know you do want to
keep in mind this tendency to
you know make decisions that aren't
always the best I'll give you some
examples for myself you know uh my first
marriage was kind of a a mess and you
know if I hadn't been grieving my
um mother who died in 2000 uh drowning
in Costa Rica and I had to handle her
estate and sort of like you know getting
to the end of graduate school and
feeling like it was time to settle down
there's no way I would have stayed with
that person let alone had children with
them and I'm happy about the kids but
you know I I really did
um lose out on a lot of stuff as a
result
um you know those are the sort of
decisions people make job decisions
people make other relationship decisions
people engage with their environment or
their family in ways that are
reinforcing that depression sometimes
you know because they can feel like oh
life has given me a lot of you know
crappy stuff to deal with right and so
you want to try to reframe these matters
and realize that you do you do have some
agency it's probably not a ton of agency
but at least some in deciding for
yourself what you're going to do if your
job really sucks it's not to say you can
snap your fingers and find another job
you know next week but it's not there's
nothing that says You must stay in a job
that you find is grinding you down and
you hate you know so that's that's kind
of important
um
our involvement with other peoples
another thing I talked about are
relationships our interactions whether
we're competitive and comparing
ourselves with them or whether we're
able to get in on common projects which
can sometimes be big disappointments
right we are more committed than other
people to some common good all of these
figure into whether we feel depressed
whether we stay depressed how we move
out of it how we keep ourselves in it
and so you know we want to pay attention
to those aspects as well that was
something that I talked about in the the
previous video and then you know a few
other things as I wrap up
so
it's not as if with most people who are
depressed that it's all in their head
or all in their blood chemistry or brain
chemistry or something like that right
people have genuine things to feel bad
and sad and to grieve about you know my
mother dying
um yes I was somebody who struggled with
depression did I grieve for her because
I was depressed no I grieved for her
because that's what you do as a human
being who loves and cares about and now
is lacking the other person and feels
bad about how they died too and the
years of life that they missed out on
and experiences that they they lost
getting to see their grandchildren as as
a result that is normal and this is one
of the struggles that a lot of people
face when it comes to depression
themselves and they also face this
because other people will sometimes say
oh well you're depressed that's that's
the explanation for why you aren't happy
with your job I mean and your job can
suck right or your job can go from being
a great job and then your company gets
bought out and they start you know
changing everything around or the boss
is a different boss and you don't have a
good relationship with them like you did
with your previous boss and now your job
sucks and that's that's a reality right
it might feel worse because of your
depression but it's not just your
depression making it bad when you look
at our world I mean we just went through
a global pandemic that was badly handled
certainly here in the United States
and which a lot of people seem to
believe is over actually there's a lot
of loonies out there who you know have
crazy conspiracy theories about that
that's enough to get you depressed even
if you weren't depressed right and we're
dealing with this day by day by day I
mean we're living in a time in which
we're aware of all these terrible
problems you know mass shootings the
environmental degradation and it doesn't
seem like we can do much about it well
that that can you know that can worsen
your depression your depression can
sometimes actually be a rational
response to things being crappy now
dividing the parts of it you know where
is the reasonable part where is the
irrational uh part that's really you
know a problem there's no need dividing
line between them but it's important to
realize that these things do in fact go
together if you're in an abusive
relationship you're not feeling like
crap just because you're depressed you
may be depressed because you're trapped
in an abusive relationship and you're
not sure how to get get the hell out of
it right so there's lots and lots of
things like that and I think it's
important for people who are depressed
and are facing challenges adversities
you know problems uh bad relationships
to understand and to be gentle with
themselves about how it is that they
feel because of the things that they're
being affected by
um
the other thing I do want to say
something about uh just to bring this to
an end is philosophy I've mentioned that
I found philosophy at least certain
philosophies certain philosophers
helpful for understanding and dealing
with depression again there's no like
magic recipe there's no buy this book
and everything is going to improve and
and you'll you know suddenly feel
wonderful again
um but there are I found certain
philosophers useful so I went back to
the video and I looked at who I talked
about I talked about Aristotle Epictetus
uh Plato John Cassian Surin Kierkegaard
Gabriel Marcel uh Hegel and William
James and I would say all of those are
still helpful interlocutors for me
they're helpful in different ways I mean
none of them are saying I've Got A
Treatise here on depression and here's
what you need to do but it's more like
they give you interesting perspectives
and resources and sometimes they're just
like showing you how to think through
things like Hegel is good for that or
Kierkegaard is kind of a good model or
Plato or or Aristotle right
um you know the dialectical method as we
see in different ways with these these
different people can be quite useful for
you and there can be
philosophical practices or as you know
pure adult calls them spiritual
exercises in their works that you might
find helpful since then I would say you
know who have I added to the mix
um
it's kind of an interesting thing to
look at Plutarch I've done a lot more
reading and work on him and I appreciate
him quite a bit Marcus Tulia Cicero I
find a lot of the things that he has to
say quite useful and I can relate to the
guy too not that I was offered to become
a part of the ruling party and you know
turn them down and fought a civil war
but how we processed grief and how he
dealt with setbacks you know I find
quite and the projects that he had in
mind quite relatable
um
you know reading Augustine and thinking
about the grief that he went through as
a young man well even at an adolescent
really with the loss of of his friend
that's quite helpful Seneca
um somebody I've really enjoyed Marcus
Aurelius too you notice there's quite a
few stoics in there
um so you know and then some
existentialists I would say reading
Simone de bouvoir has sometimes been
quite helpful for me also Jean-Paul
sarte Albert cammu
Friedrich Nietzsche you know love
shastoff is is somebody I really quite
like and I'm just throwing names at you
of people I mean you notice that I do
videos on these people because I think
that their works are useful and I expose
students to them it's not that studying
Philosophy by itself will automatically
make everything fall into place again it
to go back to that metaphor that I was
using before it's more like pulling on
different threads and the ball slowly
unravels and gets into something like
the shape that you want and here's where
I'm gonna I'm gonna finish up because
this is already getting way too long but
I hope this is helpful for you
I think that when it comes to depression
um
at least I find the goal is not to get
rid of it all together
it's not to transform myself into a
shiny happy person or anything like that
it's to be able to manage better to
you know have a better life
a life with better relationships a life
where I prioritize things in ways that I
can look at later and say yeah I didn't
screw that up so much as I did in the
past I think it's important to have
expectations for yourself to set a bar
but not to set it too high and it's
important to recognize that the the good
that you experience that you produce
that you provide is genuinely good even
if it's limited even if it's got flaws
in it even if it's going to disappear in
a hundred years from now it's still real
if you have a good interaction with a
person if you help a student learn
something even if they're going to
forget it you know two weeks from now
you did something that is valuable even
if your job is just like you know saying
hello to people who are coming into a
store like readers at Walmart
that's something
and you know smiling at a person uh
who's having a bad day
um being able to create you know a small
plot of something that's growing and may
even be beautiful like flowers those are
real things
petting your your cat and hearing them
purr and giving them some pleasure and
comfort and security that is something
real and so our lives and the good parts
of our Lives the things that depression
often robs us of the ability to
appreciate
is composed of all these little things
these little achievements these little
wins you could say and so don't let it
take uh those away from you that's
that's going to be my last word here
other than to say once again if you are
somebody who suffers from depression or
you have you know a close friend a
colleague a family member who suffers
from it I I empathize with you I you
know I won't say I know exactly what
it's like for you and nor will anybody
else who is realistic about it but
there's something to being able to say
yeah I get it I get what you're going
through and you're not without value
because you struggle with this
particular thing that we call depression